nearly one in four american women will
have an abortion before they are 45
but this reproductive right is now under
threat how are you feeling i am angry
not ever no so say it with me we are not
going
[Applause]
a shock leak of a draft supreme court
ruling indicates that the conservative
majority intend to overturn roe versus
wade
the landmark 1973 ruling that made
access to abortion a constitutional
right
while those on the right celebrate
others fear for the future of civil
liberties in america
it's difficult to imagine
just how
devastating an impact this will have
on
future generations of
american women
[Music]
it's a huge shock this is
you know it's a huge supreme court story
it's a bigger women's rights story but
the leak itself is something
that has never happened before this is
the institution in washington that was
known as as leak proof
where the clerks and the justices are
really a pretty tight family
they have utter confidence
um
in the in the confidentiality of their
papers and their proceedings until the
rulings are released
uh so
there's it seems there's something
rotten in the state of the supreme court
for someone
to do something as norm-shattering and
rule-breaking
as to release this opinion weeks early
abortion has been around since pregnancy
has been around
it's just become safer
and easier to procure
so if roe vs wade is overturned the
result will not be abortions ending
abortion will be will continue to be
legal in certain states and safe and in
other places it'll be hard to get and
unsafe abortion practices women left
alone
women
resorting to
deeply
troublingly dangerous abortion methods
when they don't have other options
are going to rise and we're going to see
more injuries and more deaths from women
who are attempting to end their
pregnancies
in states where they don't have the
right to access it it's not that
uncommon for the supreme court to
overrule itself
um
but it's it's never happened that a
constitutional right has simply been
erased
constitutional rights through additional
opinions of the court have been modified
have been expanded many times
um have been tweaked but pulling the rug
out from under
american women in this way is something
that the court has never deigned to do
the other
huge story the other worry
is that this could be the beginning of
a revolution in the way that the
constitution is interpreted
um
the constitution is a spare document it
doesn't have a lot of words it's one of
the world's shortest
and it doesn't provide for things like a
right to education or health care
or have provisions for privacy
contraception abortion
so
there's
there's just a lot of uncertainty
in a post-row world about
how far a conservative majority
that is six to three
on the court might go in striking down
other
other rights that are unpopular among
conservatives
and viewed with suspicion i worry not
just about the future of civil liberties
but about the future of the court
and americans confidence in it
and their ability to view it as a
tribunal
that
really
provides a fair procedure
for adjudicating cases that affect the
lives of so many people
and i think that's a dangerous situation
to read our latest coverage of abortion
rights in america click the link and
don't forget to subscribe